[Music]
thank you so much for inviting me um as
I was trying to think what would be a
good topic to present at this talk the
organizers were really nice and so a lot
of things that you'll hear today was
influenced by what the organizers
thought was important cuz there really
so many things happening that are
exciting to talk about in the agentic
landscape so let's get started the first
thing was um late 2021 I think LMS
really uh were starting to capture the
imagination as a company we've been
investing in AI for almost almost 15 16
years so we decided we'll build our own
um we'll build our own large language
model took all of 2022 to do that and
2023 we wrote a paper about it we had
learned a lot about how do you build
these models how do you organize uh data
sets for these how does evaluation work
how do you Cox performance in certain
zones out of this but then chat GPT
happened I think the open weight and the
open source Community has come up so uh
beautifully along so while we continue
to do very similar
work as a strategy we pivoted to say
let's build on top of uh whatever is
available out there we have many many
different use cases so I think we we
pretty much pivoted to say We'll build
on top uh if it helps you in any way on
how we are doing things so there you go
uh the other was uh I think there was a
curiosity on how exactly uh does a
company like Bloomberg organize its AI
efforts so um I report into I report to
the uh Global head of engineering and we
are organized somewhat as a special
group if you will we work a lot with our
data counterpart Bloomberg is a really
strong large data organization that you
can appreciate now helps us out a lot uh
we work with the product the CTO in in
cross functional settings about 400
people 50 teams London New York uh
Princeton and Toronto so that's a little
bit about our our
group okay so um we've been uh Building
Products using generative AI um starting
with tools more agentic for 12 to 16
months now I think the effort has been
really really serious and so there have
been so many things we've had to solve
in order to build something today using
what's available today uh and then I
decided somebody must cover all of these
topics so I'm not going to talk about
these at all right uh I think there are
some wonderful speakers talking about
this uh I'll try to hang around a bit
after this and I'm really um I'm really
bullish on what the developments are in
any one of those challenges that we need
to solve I think it gets easier and
easier to solve those challenges so
please don't read these as being
pessimistic it's just realistic right I
need to build and ship things today and
that means these are the things I need
to deal with today uh again we won't be
touching on any of these topics
today um so internally it was really
hard to say what's an agent and what's a
tool because everyone kind of had their
own vocabulary and then this really nice
paper came out so when I'm talking today
when I say a tool I mean on the left
hand side of that uh it's cognitive
architectures for for language agents if
you haven't read it you should uh try to
read that paper and then an agent is
really like more autonomous has memory
can evolve so whenever I say agentic
it's on the right hand side of the
spectrum and the other one is the left
hand side um so that's what my
vocabulary will
be finally to set the stage for the talk
um I don't know how many of you know
about Bloomberg I certainly did not know
as much as I do today when I joined so
um we are a fintech company as you can
imagine from my nice uh jacket or
jumper and our clients are in finance
but Finance is a very diverse field so
uh I'm listed here 10 different
archetypes of people who are in finance
and they do very different activities
but they also do a lot of similar
activities and so um what is like a
short form of thinking what Bloomberg
does we have we both generate and
accumulate a lot of data this is
unstructured and structured so news
research uh documents slides we uh also
provide access to we we sites there's a
lot of reference data uh Market data
coming in so if you just want to know
the scale every day we get 400 billion
pics of structured data information
about a billion plus um unstructured
messages millions of well-written
documents which include news and this is
just every day and we have over 40 years
of history on it so when we say we offer
information as one of the things to our
clients this is the scale at which we
are working
uh the rest of this talk I will uh as
you can imagine we are building a very
broad set of products so to focus the
talk I'll talk about one
particular uh archetype uh research
analyst if you didn't know what a
research anal is done here is a does
here is a short course so uh there's a
research analyst they are typically an
expert in a particular area think like
you know I'm a research analyst in AI or
semiconductors or technology or electric
vehicles and the kinds of things they
need to do on a daily basis are written
at the bottom so they are doing a lot of
work with search and Discovery and
summarization a lot of things with
unstructured data on the leftand side
they are doing a lot of work in uh in
data and analytics structured data and
analytics in the middle part of the
segment they are reaching out to their
colleagues both to disperse and gather
information so there's a lot of
communication and then they're also also
uh some of them are also building models
uh which means they need to normalize
data they need to actually program and
generate models as well so this is a a
research analyst in a uh in a
nutshell uh the other bit is because we
are in finance and we've been here for
we've been in finance for like since
founding 40 years ago there are some
aspects of our products that are
non-negotiable and uh those include
things like precision comprehensiveness
speed throughput availability um some
principles like protecting our
contributor and client data making sure
that whatever we build there is
transparency throughout these are
non-negotiables it doesn't matter
whether you're using AI or not so these
should ground you in the kinds of
challenges we face when we use what's
available today to build
agents okay so what was the first thing
we did uh again 2023 is when I think we
got serious so the first thing we did
was for the research in the in the zone
of helping the research analyst
community
um companies public companies in
particular they have scheduled quarterly
calls that discuss the health of their
company they talk about their future
it's a conference call a lot of analysts
attend the call uh there's a
presentation by the company's Executives
and then there's a Q&A segment and
during earning season it happens that on
any given day many many of these things
are happening so I told you that a
research analyst has to stay on top of
what's happening every single day so
so transcripts of these calls need to be
generated again AI is used and in 2023
we saw an opportunity to say well we
know what for every company which is a
which is operating in a particular
sector we know what are the kinds of
questions are of interest and maybe we
can try to answer them for the analyst
to take a look at and that way they can
be informed on whether they wanted to
deeper dive or not right seems like a
simple product and again I'm talking
about work that started in 23 so
where the technology was we still needed
to do a lot to bring it to the market
keeping our principles and features in
place so what does it mean just focus on
the right hand side if you will um
performance out of the box was not great
like Precision accuracy uh factuality
things like that uh and for those of you
who are interested in mlops I think
there was a lot of work done in order to
just build remediation workflows and
circuit breakers because remember these
summaries are not somebody just chatting
with a transcript it's actually
published and everyone gets to see the
same summary and anything that is an
error has an outsized impact for us so
we constantly monitor performance
remediate and then the summaries get
more and more accurate so a lot of um I
think a lot of monitoring goes in behind
it a lot of cicd goes in behind it as
well okay so today how are the products
that we are building how does the
agentic architecture look like well
first of all it's semi- agentic because
I don't this is an opinion we don't yet
fully have the trust that everything can
be autonomous so there are some pieces
that are autonomous the other pieces
that are not autonomous guard rails is a
classic example of for example Bloomberg
doesn't offer Financial advice so if
someone starts with hey should I invest
in then you know you need to catch it we
need to be factual that's again a
guardrail so like those are not optional
pieces for any agent those are coded in
as you must uh you must do this check so
just take this keep this image in mind
it'll come back okay so this is about
this is a talk about scaling so with
that long Runway let's get to scaling so
I just wanted to cover two aspects of
scaling I'm hoping that both these
aspects will be more of a confirmation
and not a surprise to any of you um so
let's see so the first thing is if you
want to build agents and you want each
agent to evolve really quickly because
when you build the first time unless
you're a magician it's going to suck a
bit and then it needs to improve and
improve and improve right so how do you
get there well let's go back to how some
really good software is built when I was
a grad student I use matrix
multiplication a lot and this is a
snapshot of the generalized Matrix
matrix product and if you read the API
documentation it lays out every aspect
of the input every error code how long
it will take is also available in
documentation it's just it just works
right and when you build software on top
of such really well documented
well-written software your software also
tends to be robust your products tend to
be robust even from 20 years ago when we
started using machine learning to build
products like you know there are tools
like apis that use models or pipelines
of models behind them you as a caller or
a person Downstream of such apis there
is a bit of stoas stochasticity if I can
pronounce it correct uh in right you
don't quite know what the result will be
and you don't quite know if it'll work
for you or not and this is despite best
intentions of establishing you know what
the input distributions are and what the
output distributions are there's always
a bit of stochasticity it was still okay
to work with them and I'll tell you why
it was okay to work with these but when
you enter using llms and agents which
are really compositions of llms the
errors multiply a lot and that is
something that causes a lot of fragile
behavior and I and we'll just take a
look at it and and I I hope my answer is
mildly surprising to you on how to avoid
the
fragility um in 2009 we
built uh a news sentiment product it was
basically to detect if a piece of news
for a given company would be beneficial
for that company or
not so the input distribution we knew
which news wires we were monitor
monitoring we knew which language it was
in news wires also have editorial
guidelines on how they write things so
well it's while this while the API that
sits in front of the model is not as
clean as like Matrix Matrix multiply you
still have a very decent handle on okay
what is coming into my system and the
outputs are obviously just like you know
it's minus one to plus one pretty much
so like the output space is also very
easy training data we built it from
scratch so we know the training data we
could have really nice held out in time
and space um
test sets and then we could establish
the risk of deploying this we could
monitor it so despite all of this guard
rail being present we still ended up
having a lot of outof band communication
on anyone who's Downstream of us so for
example if you were consuming our stream
of output on sentiment we would give you
a heads up we would tell you that hey
the model version is changing if you
have a downstream application using this
as a signal you want to test it out
things like that this was the landscape
that's changed a lot when you think
about building agentic architectures
like you want to make improvements to
your agents every single day you don't
want to have a release cycle where there
is a you know a purely batch regression
test based release cycle because there
are so many customers who are Downstream
of you who are also making independent
improvements to your model so I'll give
you like one small example right so uh
one of the one of the workflows that we
have agents for is um for a research
analyst is uh I told you that structured
data is something that they look at the
question here is US CPI for the last
five quarters Q is just a quarter
there's an agent that deeply understands
the query uh figures out what domain it
should dispatch to and then uses a tool
it's there's an NLP front end to the
tool but uses a tool to basically fetch
the data right
um turns out that the data is wrong and
which is why you need the guard rails
the data is wrong because of one
character that was missed uh it monthly
data as opposed to quarterly data and if
you're actually building a downstream
workflow where you're not even exposing
the table a good research analyst would
catch it but if you're not even exposing
the table and you're just looking at an
answer that says well it looks like the
answer is 42 it's really hard to catch
these compounding errors which is
why it is easier to not count on the
Upstream systems to be accurate but
rather factor in that they will be
fragile and they'll be evolving and just
do your own safety checks even in like
I'm talking about within my own arc
people are independently operating every
version of the data and analy analytics
API tool that's coming out is better and
better but being better means being
better on average it doesn't mean it'll
be better for you as a downstream
consumer so building
in some of
this um guard rail I just think is good
sense and that almost makes you go
faster as as you factor out individual
agents and each agent can evolve without
having these handshake signals of well
every Downstream caller I have I have to
make sure that they understand what's
changed and they sign off that I can
actually release my I can promote my um
new agent to like beta or production I
think we just need to like change that
mindset and be more
resilient so that's one the second thing
is as much as I used to code one one one
fine day long long ago I'm a manager now
so I thought I'll talk about Arc
structure and I don't know how many of
you will um resonate with it Bloomberg
like I said we've been building these
things for like 15 years and traditional
machine learning um it has a particular
factorization of software and that
software factorization is then reflected
in the arc structure if you are lucky
you have the reverse Conway uh law of
design but you but you really need to
rethink that as you start using
different text stacks and start building
different kinds of products um what do
what do I
mean how many agents Do you want to
build and what should each agent do and
should agents have overlapping
functionality or not these are some
basic questions and typically it's very
tempting to just say let's just keep our
current software stack and see if we can
build on top of that or let's keep our
current Arc structure and build on top
of that and so what I've learned
is on the columns here you can see you
know the first two columns are
vertically aligned teams the next two
columns are horizontally aligned teams
and there are some properties in the
rows and what we've learned and we've
actually done some reog what we've
learned are in the beginning you don't
really know much on what the product
design is going to be and you want to
iterate fast it's just easier to like
collapse The Arc collapse the software
stack and just say here has a team go
build what needs to be built and figure
things out and that's where you want
like you know really fast iteration you
want sharing of code data models things
like
that the more you have understood this
for a single product or a single agent
the more you understand what its use is
and what it's good at and what it's not
and you actually build many many of
these agents and that's when you start
thinking okay I can go back to the
foundations of building good software
and good Orcs And I want to have things
like optimization on it so I want to
increase the performance reduce the cost
make it more testable make it more
transparent and that's where you move
into the bottom right corner of the
segment where you do have some
horizontal so in our case like guard
rails are horizontal we don't want every
team every one of those 50 teams like
trying to figure out what does it mean
for me to not
accept user inputs that are thinly
wailed Financial advice inputs right
like like it's something that you want
to do horizontally but you don't also
don't want to you want to figure out for
yourself what is the right
time uh for you and your organization to
start creating horizontals to also start
breaking out some of these
monolithic agents which are reflected
again in your structure and start
creating smaller and smaller
pieces so all that said and done like
you know just again for the uh running
example of a research agent this is how
it looks like today so you know I think
taking in the user user world and and
session context and deeply understanding
what is the question and then figuring
out what kinds of information are needed
to answer that question uh it's
factorized as its own agent uh reflected
in the art structure same similarly for
answer generation we have a lot of uh
rigor around what constitutes a
well-formed answer again that's factored
out I call it semi agentic like I
alluded to before because we do have
guard rails that are non optional there
is no autonomy there you have to call it
at multiple points um and then yeah like
we build on top of like years of
traditional uh and more and more modern
forms of data monging like you know your
sparse indices have become dense and
hybrid indices now so yeah that's a
little bit and I think I'm brighter time
so have a nice day thank you
[Music]